comme dans les hauts de france ou en
ile-de-france nos départements
doivent-ils se préparer aussi à de
nouvelles restrictions voire un
troisième confinement le beau temps est
propice au relâchement des gestes
barrières et les taux d'incidence ne
baissent plus ni à tourny à blois le
point sur la situation et les derniers
chiffres en indre et loire et en
loir-et-cher avec romain delville en
indre et loire comme en loir-et-cher les
taux d'incidence covit s'emballe il
dépasse dans les deux départements les
270 personnes pour 100000 habitants le
taux de positivité et de 8,3 pour cent
avec une augmentation des données chez
les 0 15 ans et les 15 45 ans l'autre
indicateur qui compte pour prendre de
nouvelles mesures sanitaires c'est le
nombre de passions qu'ovide en région
centre val de loire
cent cinquante personnes sont
actuellement hospitalisées pour être
soigné du coc vide mais c'est un lys
hospitalier la moyenne d'âge a baissé
donc on a moins de personnes très âgées
on a des gens en effet un peu moins âgée
que lors des vagues précédentes
c'est un indicateur qui fait aussi dire
que ça évolue
parmi les raisons évoquées la plus
grande contagiosité du variant 10
anglais qui représente 70% des tests
positifs
et puis il y a peut être un relâchement
dû à l'arrivée des vaccins et des beaux
jours
comme a pu le constater samedi sur la
place plumereau un témoin qui nous a
transmis ces images des jeunes pour
certains non masqués qui se regroupent
entre amis ça devenait difficile pour
faire des rencontres
parce que forcément on va moins voire
moins à voir les autres gens qu'on
connaît pas spécialement parce qu'on
avait envie non plus de de trop se
mélanger genre quand même pas mal
j'essaye de vivre malgré la période
actuelle donc mais bon je pense qu'à
l'avenir avec legault le bouton il ya de
plus en plus de gens qui vont sortir
certainement rejoindre dès les quais à
cause de la fermeture notamment des
cafés brasseries où l'on se réunisse et
souvent l'après midi je vois rarement de
gens ou alors des connaissances que je
croise à place jean jaurès ou est dans
la rue on
ce qui concerne les vaccins la préfète
détaillera jeudi la montée en puissance
pour les semaines à venir
en indre et loire selon nos confrères de
la nouvelle république
la salle de spectacle l'escale à saint
cyr et le gymnase robert pouzioux à
saint-avertin devrait accueillir des
grands centres de vaccination à partir
de la mi-avril